[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le Président
bourlange pour le groupe
démocrate s'il vous
plaît
le général de Gaulle disait que quand
mauisco deurville entrer dans une salle
la température baisser de 5 degr je
crains de devoir m'inscrire après les
flots d'é loocances que j'ai entendu
dans cette tradition madame la
présidente madame la première-
ministre madame la
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues le 29 novembre
1947 l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies décidé par 33 voix contre
13 la création de l'État
d'Israël tout en prononçant pronon soin
pardon de proposer l'institution
parallèle d'un État
palestinien qui à la suite de la guerre
qui a accueilli la décision
onusienne n'a jamais pu voir le jour de
ce vote
solennel qui engage la communauté
internationale date à la fois le droit
imprescriptible du peuple juif à vivre
dans un état libre et souverain et le
lancinant problème
posé par l'émergence indéfiniment
différée de son jumeau
palestinien Israël était né Ismaël
restait dans les limbes la tragédie
prenait ses marques au cœur d'un
Moyen-Orient par ailleurs déchiré par la
guerre
froide le 7 octobre dernier C
interminable tragédie a pris un cours
décisivement nouveau et d'une gravité
exceptionnel Israël s'est trouvé
confronté à une agression paramilitaire
de première grandeur mené par un Hamas
résolu à piétiner tous les principes
toutes les règles tous les usages
régissant les relations entre les
peuples que ceuxci soit en guerre ou en
paix si les mots ont un sens il est
clair que l'agression conduite par le
Hamas est à la fois
terroriste constitutif d'un crime de
guerre généralisé et adossé à un
discours à caractère génocidaire
assumé le Hamas met en scène les pires
violences sur les populations dans le
seul but d'effrayer et d'intimiter c'est
du terrorisme le Hamas ne fait la guerre
qu'au civile c'est la même et dans son
extension maximale du crime de
guerre les fidèles du Hamas n'hésitent
pas à appeler non pas simplement à la
disparition de l'État d'Israël mais à
l'élimination des Juifs en tant que
Juifs c'est
l'expression d'une volonté de génocide
porteuse d'un crime contre
l'humanité face à une telle
entreprise israël dispose d'un droit
absolu à se défendre mais la question
fondamentale que met sous une lumière
brutale l'initiative sanglante du Hamas
c'est celle des moyen propre à assurer
la sécurité à long terme d'Israël et
c'est de la réponse à cette question que
doivent dépendre nos réactions à court
et à moyen terme comme celle de l'État
hébreu comment un état de
200770 km car peuplé de moins de 7
millions de Juifs faire vience d'une
communauté humaine de près de de TR de
près de 13 millions de personnes
pourrait-il espérer vivre durablement en
paix et en sécurité au milieu d'un
environnement par hypothèse style de
plus d'un milliard et demi de musulmans
à cette question la mauvaise réponse
mais aussi la plus tentante et bien
entendu celle du mur du cordon sanitaire
supposé pouvoir soustraire l'État hébreu
puissamment militarisé à toutes les
menaces qui l'entourent la combinaison
de la faiblesse démographique d'Israël
et d'une diffusion générale d'armes de
destruction de courte et de moyenne
portée a progressivement créé une
situation d'extrême vulnérabilité
sécuritaire pour l'État hébreu même
l'arme nucléaire dont dispose Israël
n'est pas de nature à assurer la survie
d'un état concentrant toute sa
population sur un espace aussi
restreint pour définir ce que doit être
la politique de la France celle de
l'Union européenne et plus généralement
celle de la communauté internationale
face à cette terrible situation il faut
analyser sans œillère ni préjugé ce qui
s'est modifié ces dernières années sur
la scène moyenne orientale comme l'a
très justement dit Monseigneur Vesco
archevêque d'Alger la violence barbare
du Hamas est sans excuse mais pas sans
cause avant la prise de pouvoir de
Monsieur netaniaahou les grands
dirigeants historiques d'Israël quel que
étit leur sensibilité politique ont eu
une conscience aigue de cette
vulnérabilité après que la guerre du Kip
pour les les lui rendu manifeste Isaac
Rabine qui avait vu au plus près le
péril de la patrie apporter avec une
force de conviction et une volonté
politique sans pareil l'idée qu'il n'y
aurait ni paix ni sérénité pour Israël
si les parlementaires ne voent ne se
voyaient pas reconnaître eux aussi un
État libre et souverain mais narem bégim
venu
pourtant de la droite de la
droite assumé courageusement qu'and DESV
le choix le choix de la paix avec le
principal ennemi d'Israël l'Égypte
postnassyrienne Ariel Charon qui avait
pris la mesure de l'impuissance de la
force dans le cadre de l'intervention
controversée qu'il avait conduite au
Liban avait à la veille de l'accident de
santé qui devait le terrasser décidé
d'amener son pays à renoncer à ses
ambitions coloniales en 6 Jordanie ces
hommes avaient pressenti et pour Isaak
Rabine a tout le moins pleinement
reconnu qu'Israël ne trouverait la paix
qu'à la condition d'établir avec les
États arabes qui l'entourer mais aussi
avec les hommes et les femmes de
Palestine une relation équilibrée
qui supposerait le respect mutuel et le
partage des bénéfices de la
paix la rupture introduite ces dernières
années dans la politique israélienne par
les gouvernements successifs de monsieur
nitambu n'est certainement pas la cause
unique de la situation nouvelle mais
elle y a puissamment contribué le
Premier ministre israélien et son
gouvernement construit en rupture avec
la tradition laïque et libérale qui a
dominé l'histoire intérieure d'Israël
depuis sa création ont paru méconnaître
cette vulnérabilité structurelle de
l'État hébreu et ont agit comme si le
problème palestinien appartenait au
passé et qu'il n'y avait plus lieu de
prendre en compte les attentes et de
redouter les initiatives issues d'une
communauté palestinienne divisé
disqualifié et dans ses formes les plus
extrêmes celles du ramass tout
simplement acheté par son ennemi sur le
plan
technique il est clair que monsieur
netanahou qui est sans doute le moins
versé dans les affaires militaires de
tous les chefs de gouvernement qui se
sont succédés à son poste depuis la
création d'isarel n'a pas su maintenir
entre le pouvoir politique tal et les
services de renseignement l'étroite
solidarité nécessaire à une mobilisation
de tous les instants de l'appareil
sécuritaire sur les bons en jeux à court
terme ces défaillances se sont révélé
lourdes de
conséquences l'essentiel s'il vous plaît
l'essentiel est toutefois d'ordre
politique monsieur monsieur netanahou a
semblé imaginer que l'établissement de
relations apaisées et coopérativ avec
les voisins arabes d'Israël ce qui était
en soit une excellente ambition et se
révélera demain fort utile à la quête
nécessaire de la p
pouvait avoir ce pouvoir indirect mais
précieux à ses yeux de dispenser Israël
de rechercher un accord équilibré et
respectueux des attentes de leurs
aspirations profondes avec les
Palestiniens bien plus les accords
d'Abraham ayant permis aux États arabes
d'abandonner les Palestiniens à leur
triste sort le gouvernement israélien s
s'est estimer libre d'engager sans
risque une relance rampante mais brutale
et déterminée de sa politique de
colonisation en
6jordanie la politique d'Israël a changé
mais il serait injuste d'attribuer à
l'État hébreu le monopole de la nouvelle
brutalisation du monde d'où l'horreur du
7 octobre est sortie partout les forces
attachées à la modération à la
coopération et à la paix ont été batttu
en brèche que les Palestiniens est eu la
tentation croissante et suicidaire de se
réfugier dans une sorte de nilisme
politique ne peut pas nous surprendre
une population sans avenir donc sans
espoir pouvait-elle être tentée par des
partis modérés qui n'avaient rien à lui
offrir mais les
États-Unis les États-Unis ont eux aussi
ont eux aussi leur part de
responsabilité historique dans
l'armement du piège qui n'avait guerre
les États-Unis qui n'avait guerre
encouragé les efforts des Européens en
faveur d'un processus de paix fondé sur
la quête d'une une solution à deux états
et qui a l'initiative de Donald Trump
ont basculé dans le camp des pouss au
crimes en cassant les accords de Paris
avec l'Iran et en cautionnant le
transfert de leur ambassade à
Jérusalem l'Europe n quant à elle manque
a quant à elle manqué ni à la lucidité
ni à l'imagination dans son obstination
à soutenir le seul modèle capable de
transformer en partenairire des
adversaires de toujours mais elle s'est
révélé incapable de IR le choc quand le
président Trump a décidé de sonner la
charge contre toute solution d'équilibre
et de bon sens force des analyses
faiblesses des
volontés
le excusez-moi un court instant comment
dans ces conditions ne pas voir que ce
sont aujourd'hui les héritiers
idéologiques des assassins d'oir el
Sadat et d'Isaac Rabine qui tiennent
ensemble la plume de la tragédie qui
s'écrit sous nos
yeux que pouvons-nous faire pour aider
les peuples pour aider les peuples en
détresse à tracer le bon chemin dans
l'immédiat il faut impérativement
veiller à ce qu'une contre-attaque
légitime dès lors qu'elle vise
exclusivement à détruire les moyens
militaires de l'agresseur évite les deux
écueils majeurs que chacun a clairement
identifié d'abord le risque d'une
escalade incontrôlée pouvant conduire à
un rasement général derrière le Hamas il
y a le hzbollah derrière le hzbollah il
y a l'Iran derrière l'Iran il y a la
Russie et la Chine rendons à cet égard
un juste hommage au sang-froid et
l'engagement du président Biden qui au
rebours de son prédécesseur met
indiscutablement tout le poids des
États-Unis au service de la modération
de la désescalade de la libération des
otages et du droit à la vie des
populations civiles le deuxème risque
majeur c'est en effet celui d'un
anéantissement massif des populations
civiles utilisé par les uns comme des
boucliers humains et par les autres
comme l'exitoire d'une tentation de
vengeance pour reprendre l'expression
préoccupante du Premier ministre
israélien la France la France la
première ministre l'a justement rappelé
s'est engagé avec force sur cet enjeu
essentiel au-delà des mises en garde
l'Union européenne doit prendre
onsabilit pour assurer avec les
organisations humanires l'achement
massif des moyens de survie d'une
population civile en détresse profonde
et sachons faire de ces gestes fort
l'instrument du retour des otages il est
des moment et des lieux où il est
criminel de ne pas être au rendez-vous
l'Europe se relèverait pas d'être resté
passive dans des circonstancesussi
dramatiques reste à construire un avenir
de paix la tâche est redoutable en
raison du mur de détresse et de haine
qui sépare aujourd'hui Israëliens et
Palestiniens aujourd'hui il est à la
fois trop grand il est à la fois trop
tard et trop tôt pour instituer deux
états en terre de Palestine il est en
revanche temps et même grand temps de
commencer de réaliser les conditions qui
rendront possible le moment venu cette
double création la première de ces
conditions c'est qu'Israël fa cessé sa
politique de colonisation et reconnaisse
enfin que la solution du problème
palestinien ne serait passé par
l'exportation en Égypte des Palestiniens
de l'Ouest et en Jordanie des
Palestiniens de l'Est la seconde de ces
conditions c'est de recréer avec l'appui
notamment des états modérés du pacte
d'Abraham une Autorité palestinienne
active respectée et capable prend gaz le
relais d'un Hamas en cendre et de
négocier un statut respectueux des
droits
palestiniens au-delà du Moyen-Orient les
bonnes volontés existent t celle du
Brésil dont la France a eu raison de
soutenir le projet de résolution à l'ONU
il nous appartient à nous associer à
leurs efforts je terminerai je suis le
porte-parole du MoDem je suis donc tenu
à une double exigence tenir un discours
équilibré faits et défendre la cause
européenne je terminerai en évoquant le
rôle essentiel que doit jouer l'Union
européenne au service de la paix dans
cette région tourmentée mais si proche
l'Europe brisée et ruinée c'est
reconstruite sur une idée excusez-moi je
me sens pas très bien sur une idée
simple et forte celle qui a guidé la
réconciliation franco-allemande on ne
peut trouver la paix avec ses
adversaires de toujours qu'à la
condition de prendre en le besoins
légitimes c'est à l'Europe de convaincre
palestinien et israéliens de la
pertinence de son logiciel de
réconciliation et c'est à la France de
convaincre nos partenaires de relever ce
défi historique je merci beaucoup
monsieur le président